[Music]
everyone that's Steven job with Collider
and I'm at the collider studio at the
Kia Telluride supper suite at Sundance I
want to give a huge thank you to Kia for
being an awesome sponsor it's the only
reason we get to be here Sundance is
expensive so huge thank you to Kia
everyone congratulations on the movie
sincerely thank you I definitely want to
jump in right from the from the
beginning and say for people that don't
realize this was a short made and I
believe 2015 so talk a little bit about
when did you realize you wanted to take
the short and you know develop it
further into a feature so we did the
short in 2015 and it premiered in France
in clermont-ferrand and from there it
just snowballed and kept you know
playing at different festivals until we
played in the Academy Theater in LA
that's when macro side and they were
interested in the characters and the
story we weren't really planning on
making it a feature but you know just
how excited the god about this story how
original it was and you know they
committed to make a feature so of course
we jumped on the opportunity well I mean
I realized I hate asking the generic
question but everyone watching this will
not have seen the movie yet so could you
actually do like how have you been
describing the film to your friends and
family like what it's about
it's a kinetic coming-of-age drama about
two rival brothers who have to come
together through a family crisis when
they move to the United States from
Columbia and they suffer a separation
okay I think that the term blast beat
that's it that's the term for the type
of music am I I'm just making yeah a
blast beat is a you know an extreme
metal it's a beat where the drums just
go superhuman speed and it's a it's an
analogy for what these guys are going
through in their lives basically for all
of you guys I'm assuming for all of you
you all read scripts and you know
there's choices to be made what was it
for each of you obviously you guys were
in the short but for for everyone what
was it about the feature that he said I
need to be in this you know what was it
about the story that really pulled at
you my tale and I
have been yeah like you said a part of
the short film and from this short we
were really I mean excited to be in a
position having the opportunity to work
together and then when instead I'm
called us maybe five years after we
finished that and said yo we're ready to
do the feature where you guys at you
ready to shave your head you ready done
it was yeah pretty much kept my hair at
middle length for like five years yeah
waiting for this you know the future was
coming I like my long hair but I knew
the future was coming at some point
maybe like two years after your hair was
like down to your [ __ ] yeah yeah it
was crazy you know one of the things
that's interesting when you get to a
point where you feel a level of
responsibility to portrayed characters
that you know that speak on behalf of a
community or a conversation that needs
to be had you know I know that in my
position I read multiple scripts in the
world of immigration border you know
border stories and I feel like there's
such a urgency to tell that story but
it's even more critical to tell it right
and when I read the script I felt like
it had all the ingredients to invite
people in the journey as opposed to make
a statement
and I think that that is important as we
humanize you know this topic in this
conversation and what happened to his
family you know
systematically I mean two-thirds of what
happened his family happen to mind right
so my family sold everything they had we
came to the United States and I know
you've described it as a time where
technology wasn't around and you
couldn't really it was very expensive to
keep in touch where'd your loved ones
back home and so you had to almost
subliminally cut ties in many ways and I
think my family did that they stole
everything they had and and we were we
were kind of alone to try to start from
scratch and then many things happen and
I think that this story hits all those
pillars and and ink and checks all those
boxes and it's entertaining it's fun
these two individuals here are an
incredible two or on a screen I mean
their performances are unbelievable and
and I couldn't be more proud to play
their daddy
I guess for me I just I mean I related
to the to the script I was taken by the
language I've never seen a Colombian
American film I wanted to be a part of
that and I wanted to see what kind of
things came up for me and a lot of
things did this your first this your
first real role in the movie doesn't my
first time acting ever yeah I was really
excited to be a part of a project that
was introducing Colombian characters
that are not like stereotypes you know I
feel like a lot of people when they
think of Colombia they think of certain
you know certain certain boxes to put us
in and so I was a girl especially I felt
like it was really nice to play a young
girl who was just you know emotional and
kind of showing a different side of
Colombia as well we have a lot of like
punk rock metal people so it's nice to
show that side this is my first time
acting also you know I was just really
excited to be a part of it because the
topic is incredibly relevant it's timely
it's necessary and you know the issues
are you know and the themes are ones
that people will get you know once they
watch the movie but the thing that
attracted me the most was that at its
heart it's a family drama very
specifically about a Colombian family
and though I'm not Colombian as an
immigrant myself I can relate to a lot
of these things that the family went
through so you know Wilmer and I have
been around a little bit we have the
luxury of choice and you know these
kinds of projects are not about money
they're not about anything other than
the love of the story the love of the
game the love of the people and so this
has been a really wonderful experience I
have to say I think a lot of people
watching might not realize you two are
actually brothers yeah and so I'm
totally serious people and
so I think that listen you two are
fantastic in the movie thank you and
obviously your real-life chemistry like
shines through talk a little bit about
what it's like acting with a brother and
sort of like I mean are you using a
nightmare correct yeah I mean we were I
felt like the the fighting and there's a
lot of burning hands in the film
especially with our characters I think
one of the main things real quick he's
my older brother
so I'm actually the younger one and in
the film I portray the older brother and
he's the younger brother or sitting down
but we're standing up you see this
so that dynamic you know already set the
tone for certain and and just the many
scenes like a stand really put us in
positions where he really wouldn't
wanted to have us get there so what did
we do we not fist fought but we had to
take it each other grappling on so you
know get the I mean actually feel angry
I was super in it there was a lot of
unnecessary fights that bled into our
your lives I mean I would imagine each
of you know how to get each other under
each other's you know skin I'm like what
what am I looking for
so was there at the moment where you
like threw something out there that was
maybe a little too real to get under
someone's skin or did it never go that
far I think the physical aspect was
really you know what I'm saying they're
actually getting at each other like he
was explaining the wrestling before seen
he had to be agitated so he would
literally be and I had to you know and
one scene had to separate us and we're
going pretty much 90 100% but wouldn't
Diane gets there it's kind of like okay
hold on it just becomes real I think I
tossed her in one in one of the takes my
brother now speak to each other in
English although both of our parents are
Colombian we speak to our parents in
Spanish we're detecting it was yeah it
was interesting to to speak to each
other mainly in Spanish in the film you
know it's like in the film speaking
English to each other is the weird part
and in real life speaking Spanish to
each other is strange so that also is
like a whole new dimension for telling
some sort of secret unless we're telling
some sort of secrets
I have a million questions but something
I want to ask something to everyone can
obviously answer so when you think back
on the making of the film this is for
each of you is there like a day or two
that you will always remember or a scene
that you filmed that really stands out
whether because someone really effed up
or you know what I mean like just a cool
memory from set it's a pleasant surprise
for you for me I think it was we were
shooting in Bogota is one of the
climactic scenes of the movie when they
finally realize where the whole crisis
is coming from it comes out of left
field for the characters and it's a
really emotional scene for them where
they're trying to figure out what
they're gonna do next and it's the
moment where we realize each of their
points of views into this whole
situation and there's no right or wrong
answer here it's just a really complex
problem that they're facing and when
they were performing the scene we just
it just became alive through frustration
and through you know just trying to get
the energy right and also the language
because there was there were a lot of
lines and we needed you know that was a
pinnacle moment in the movie so I was
just I always remember that scene when
we were doing it and it I still get
goosebumps by it every time I see it I
must have seen it like 200 times then
yeah I think for me me and Wilmer had a
really special scene we have a scene
where a scene where essentially I'm
disrespecting my dad he's coming at me
for something that I essentially didn't
have much to do with and I like bursting
in my room and I tell him to get out of
my room and we just have this encounter
where it just becomes really real I
remember we only did two takes of it but
I don't want to give it away but
essentially it gets really physical and
in that moment it just felt so real to
me and just the energy of me and Wilmer
you know the contact that we were having
in that moment and I remember seeing
when I was doing ADR I was just looking
back at that and every time I watched
that scene I feel a certain way just
because there was so much realness in
that moment you know it was intense yeah
the air got sucked out of there
when that moment just happened and we
were like well we got it yeah I guess
for me I feel the same way I mean that
that scene was you know we took
ourselves to a very very very real place
and and the story itself is I mean
there's so many frustrations that are
happening you know from walking into a
house you you know you weren't expecting
to go home see in a car that you know
kind of described you know what what Dad
what do you really do when you were here
waiting for us you know I mean there's a
lot of stuff you know and I think I
think that all that played in that scene
and I mean I'm grateful that's why I
have so much love and respect for them
and and our maestro here is a director
because we really let those things air
you know we give them time and obviously
was a privilege I mean we saw I believe
in these two guys so much I mean these
guys are are just different level men
and and when you work with people that
really take it that serious and they
show up to work and they're prepared I
mean beautiful things happen and that's
you know that's literally the recipe for
for art you know you show up prepared
it's gonna it's gonna work I would
actually say something along those lines
to when I was shooting on my first day
you know when you do an independent film
you never quite know what you're going
to get you know it's it's very it can be
guerrilla filmmaking and you don't know
whether the actors are up to snuff but
one of the first days I was working I
was working with Mateo and he had this
massively long monologue that had all of
this like scientific jargon in it and I
was looking at the page going like damn
and that's a lot of words it was 3:00
a.m. when we were shooting this and you
know I was wondering like does this kid
can can he do it is he an actor you know
and he went through this scene like
several times like there were a couple
times where he he didn't feel like he
got it right but he went back and did it
again and by the time we were through it
was so solid and I was so impressed by
his ability to kind of think on his feet
when he's tired
and also just his commitment to the work
you know young actors a lot of them
aren't committed to the work the way
that these two are and it was really
great and refreshing to see not only
that they're very talented at what they
do but also good people I wanted to say
something on that as well like I I
really enjoyed working with this cast
and crew like I again I didn't know what
to expect but I mean I was just along
for the ride but I every time we shot it
these guys just brought it every single
time and they would shoot them first and
then once it got to me I feel like we
were just so well rehearsed so like you
know in sync that I would just like do
one or two takes and it was fine
and then we moved on no but it was it
was just really great and then even and
then off-screen I just felt like we were
still a family like we were just we just
like we were mad tight like the entire
shoot it was really great yeah yeah I
would just say was an amazing cast to
work with the vibes were always good
energy nobody was stressed though I
think I'm used to like working in
high-stress situations all the time and
I was expecting this to be like that but
times 10 you know and so I was I was a
little bit surprised at like how relaxed
everyone was and how like everyone just
made you feel comfortable and made you
feel like you know you could you could
have a chance to do better in the next
day or whatever yeah on that note I
really I say congrats on the movie I
really hope everyone sees is it an
acquisition title is it for sale
domestic rights are for sale god I hope
it sells immediately and everyone can
see it thank you all so much for coming
in the studio a huge thank you to Kia
for being an awesome sponsor and I hope
you guys have a fantastic Sundance thank
you for your time